ليس الابناء فقط وحتى البنات البنات
جميعهم يدرسون في الجامعه
والسؤال الذي قلته ان بعضهم يقيمون في
الخارج بالاغلبيتهم يقيمون في الخارج
واولادهم يدرسون بناتهم وبنينهم ونحن
نشجعهم ونحن لا لا نستنكر هذا الامر انهم
مقيمين في الخارج وابنائهم يدرسون نتمنى
ان يكون ان يخرج ابنائهم بشيء من العلم
فحتى بني ادم تدرس وانا اذكر حتى هناك
كانت لقاءا من سي انما اهم احد المسؤوليه
طالبان وهو المتحدث الرسمي اا سيد الشاهين
قال انت بنتك تدرس في قطر وفي الجامعه
فقال نعم هي محجبه وهل للمراه الافغانيه
سيد مشاري انت تعرف جيدا وهل هناك امراه
اثنان غير محجبه سواء كانت جمهوريه او غير
جمهوريه هل هناك المراه افغانيه تصرع الى
وحش وهل هناك المراه المظلومه الافغانيه
التي دائما تحت سلطه الرجال ظلما وقهرا في
اي وقت كان فهل هذه هذه النسبه وكان وزير
التعليم طالبان يقول بان المراه الافغانيه
فاحشه والعياده بالله
والمرء والعالم الاسلامي ليست هناك فيها
دوله اسلاميه والمراه المسلمه التي تدرس
في اي مملكه اخرى فهي خلافا للاسلام اين
يوجد همم عدم الحجاب المراه الافغانيه
محجبه من عاداتها من تقاليدها حتى وان لم
تكن متعلما الاسلام
وحتى في ايام الشجاعيه نحن لا نتكلم عن
الجزئين اتكلم عن عامه وحتى ايام الشيوعيه
كانت امراه محجبه كانت وايام الجمهوريه
كانت امراه لم تكن هناك امراه غير محجبه
نعم هناك فرق بين تعريف الحجاب بين العالم
الاسلامي وبين طالبان انما المراه كانت
محجبه واذكركم بنقطه اخرى ان لم اتاخر
معالي الوزير شيخ نداء محمد وزير الطالبان
قال من اسباب منع تعليم المراه من
الجامعات على الموضوع المحرم موضوع سكنها
في في مساكن طالبات والموضوع
حجابها وعيد قال ان
المنهج الدراسي لم يكن اسلامي فانا همم
اسال السؤال
اي يعني كان المفروض ان يقول ما هو المنهج
الذي هو غير اسلامي واذا كان المنهج هذا
غير اسلامي فالمنهج غير اسلامي للبنين
والبنات فما معنى انك تمنع البنت وتترك
الولد فاذا كان المنهج غيري اسلامي فهو
المتاثر في الجميع